like awful yes like very awkward
watching that back like it made me
cringe often because there's like these
deep laughs that I have that I was
actually laughing internally at myself
being like men you're gonna look like an
idiot
which set up the most dramatic and
emotional ending in bachelor history
in order to let myself fully love one
woman I have to say goodbye to the other
I am joined now by the 20th Bachelor Ben
Higgins Ben you watched it back how was
it I didn't want to watch it at all and
actually convinced myself I wasn't going
to and then I couldn't help myself
and I I got through the first half and
skipped around on the second half
because I really want to see Olivia and
in our conversation and see how that
kind of played out for her it was really
hard to watch like God like I don't
overdramatize like it was really
embarrassing and awkward why I just
hadn't seen so many mom one you have to
watch yourself like kissing people it's
not fun either way like I don't
encourage anybody to film it and then
we'll try to watch it back for years
later you know you know you don't even
know those people anymore the next was I
noticed moments where I was trying to be
cool or smooth there I thought I was
cooler smooth I was even trying to guys
I was like I am it doesn't come off good
especially knowing myself and knowing
that internally I was just questioning
everything so it was just it was just
embarrassing
boy you know I gotta ask what moments
were you trying to be cool because you
didn't see anything I was that cool
right thanks no no could you like
succeeded so much being so cool you're
known as the coolest bachelor yeah cool
throughout but what moments could you
reveal to the people that were attempts
at being cool the first one I'd like to
start with is I'd like to get on Chris
Harrison a bit because I really think he
set me up for failure and I want to tell
you why we all knew that I was
definitely not gonna be the smoothest
most like comfortable bachelor of all
time I was this was gonna take me a
while to kind of get used to so the very
first date of the season gets set up
with Kevin Hart and ice cube driving me
around Los Angeles sitting in the
backseat so here I am with my date
they're hilarious making me laugh the
whole time making her laugh the whole
time like I'm trying to keep up and I
remember in my mind just saying the less
you say the better this will go because
you're never gonna keep up with these
two
remember that because there are always
hot tub dates on bachelor and
bachelorette you had a hot tub date on
your first date and it was indoors in a
hot tub store like awful yes like very
awkward watching that back like it made
me cringe often because there's like
these deep laughs that I had that I was
actually laughing internally at myself
being like men you're gonna look like an
idiot for this like what does that sound
like can you do that laugh for me and
then just dies it dies off real fast and
there's just this awkward like giggle so
you were not so cool on that first date
looking back do you even know that guy
have you changed a lot since that guy I
have a change lot I've just owned now
the fact that I'm not that cool and like
enjoy it so I think watch if I was the
bachelor today and I did the whole thing
over again
I think there'd still be moments many
moments that I'd be embarrassed by or
feel like have to look through my
fingers at but I do think I would own my
lack of coolness more well but that's
the thing about the show right is it in
many ways helps you figure out who you
are so many leads have said that to me
that it's a little bit like therapy you
look at yourself really really closely
yeah you do I mean I I don't think it's
weird I'll tell you I'll tell you
somebody I want to tell you last night
at dinner somebody asked me where my
best friend's could you picture your
life without doing the show and I don't
know why you know I consider you a
friend
I'm a weird dude I get really emotional
over weird stuff I start like tearing up
and I don't know why like I don't have
that much of an emotional connection to
the show anymore like I have an amazing
fiance a lot of my life doesn't focus
around and any of the show except I was
hosting a traveling bachelor show but
that's a whole day you didn't have a job
like that but okay like it's almost
scary for me to think of what my life
would have been like this show has been
so good to me and it's taught me so much
about myself and it's enhanced
experiences and salame to meet new
people and be new relationships I don't
think I'm with my fiancee now if the
show doesn't happen just because of
random circumstances so yes
Tom ela and it's been really good for me
and really fun to celebrate that from
the show rearing going yeah you 26 I'm
trying to figure it out
now look I'm still trying to figure it
out but this is a part of that story and
it's been really fun to see back so I
have to ask just as somebody you met
long after the show I know that she's
been wonderful about embracing all the
opportunities and life that the show has
brought you and that you've come with
but dude just watch this back with you
no no she ever senior season nope nope
no plans do so here's here's some about
Jess that is amazing and you know she
has had some really traumatic life
experiences she's been through some
stuff personally and in relationships
but she's never been heartbroken
romantically that's not a part of her
story and ask Jess and I kind of talked
about it like hey are there pieces of
the show you want watch do you want to
watch Kaitlyn's season I would be
nervous I don't see the benefit and I
don't think she does either I think the
the cons far away the pros I think there
would be a chance or even though it
would I have no fear that it would end
our relationship I think that that small
moments of watching me pursue and
encourage and kiss other people might be
the closest thing to like heartbreak
that she's felt romantically and I don't
want to be a part of that she doesn't
want me to be a part of that so no she's
not watching she doesn't plan on
watching ever and I'm pretty I'm pretty
okay with it and I love you crazy
what
[Music]
this is a tough question but I also had
to wonder and ask you if that decision
is in part because of what you went
through before because look you're the
bachelor who said I love you to two
women and I know that when you and
Lauren were together I interviewed you
guys a lot and you and her had to watch
back you telling Jojo I love you so did
you already feel like you went through
this experience of having to be with the
woman you're with and watch what was
pretty painful yeah I mean honestly yes
there's a lot of like correlation now I
do think the fundamentals to my
relationship with Jessica are stronger I
think that there isn't an understanding
that you know we could get through this
and be really good and I don't know if
Laura and I ever wanted actually to get
through it I think it we we were kidding
ourselves if we say we'd were but I do
remember those moments of trying to
explain myself for thinking hey this is
all good we're gonna watch his back cuz
you know I chose you this is gonna be
fine right and it wasn't it wasn't at
all and it hurt deeply and I know I did
it wasn't it was a mistake I made to
over-communicate I don't know if I want
to call a mistake it was a decision I
made to over communicate that ended up
hurting the relationship I was in and I
would not even want to risk doing that
again right now when you say you don't
know if you and Lauren even wanted to
get through it what does that mean why I
think pretty early on I don't know how
long now looking back I think we both
realized this probably especially now
you know Lauren's married I'm assuming
it's a really good relationship I don't
I don't know the insides of it I am
engaged and what I consider a really
healthy and positive relationship I've
seen what that looks like how that feels
how that operates how it encourages how
it expands life and not contracts it
like I do think Lauren I very early on
were just trying so hard to make it work
that it was just pulling pieces of us
all the time I think the older we get we
look back on our relationships and you
like reflected on this and the special
and talked about what you learn from it
and how important it was to go through
those things to get to where you are
what do you call those I love yous now
like when you look back
and as you watch it back did you watch
saying I love you too Jojo did you watch
that moment yeah look as you see the
look in her face she says what are you
know how to say that what was that like
to watch back are you sweating right now
I'm sorry I don't like that watching it
back how did it feel
I honestly I felt pain like I felt sorry
I was sorry for Jojo watching him back
now because again JoJo's great this all
ends so well until we celebrate and
where this ends up but in the moment the
damage done was on me and I watch that I
see your face and I know how it feels
and I just I was sorry that I did that
to somebody
my intentions were good my I really do
believe that my intentions were to make
everybody know that just how personal
how much I cared and how hard this was
so that you know no matter what it ended
look up with at the end like people had
an idea of how we got there and that it
was real I just over communicated I said
things that weren't wise I spoke before
I thought and I see the look in her eye
and and I I don't believe it did
hopefully take a piece of her but I know
what it feels like to be heartbroken and
I know what it feels like to to feel
like you have something so special
coming your way and then to be have it
ripped from you and I and I hope that
didn't damage Jojo I don't I don't know
if it did but I know she's good now and
I know she's having it so not fun to see
I don't forget the original question all
I remember is like like I'm stuck in
that now yeah it's just like really hard
to watch back it hurt so when you're
watching it back what is the toughest
moment to watch back overall oh she's
the ending the proposal especially now I
don't think it would have been that hard
two years ago to watch I think I could
have done it but watching it back now
it's just uncomfortable it's it's not
healthy for me to see it's not healthy
for me to to relive given my focus and
my heart and my attention to one woman
now and I'm I'm setting up boundaries in
my life to keep that healthy good seeing
myself proposed to somebody else is that
part of that healthy boundary but I did
it so
that was really hard for me to see
especially what the placemat now in life
and just how happy I am Jojo gets the
raw into this deal
Jojo leaves hurting and I have to say
goodbye to a woman who doesn't deserve
it
I don't deserve Jojo possibly the most
stressful season of The Bachelor ever um
so would you say if you regret over
communicating do you wish you hadn't
said I love you too Jojo and do you wish
you hadn't said you could have married
her yes I wish I would not have done
that
that would have that would have made but
if I did it what would be B pop talking
about today think about how much more
fun it was for every but what your final
three are all engaged or married to
other peoples so whatever you did their
pockets so yeah I should take credit for
that like I I think I played a big part
in them saying that there's better men
out there than me now a 20th Bachelor
any advice to the 25th Bachelor it's
gonna be Matt James yeah you know he I
say it every year and I mean it and I
think they prove it most of the time
they are gonna do things far greater
than I ever did and I mean that I think
these these men who have been chosen
have different personalities they're
gonna fall and not do things as well as
I did in some parts but they're gonna
have their own experience and you can't
put this show in a box you don't want to
make it the same every season my only
advice the math would be one have fun
with it it's gonna be okay you can have
some I think we've seen recently in some
past seasons you can have some massive
mix ups and you're still gonna be just
fine at the end and the next would be to
be yourself like to these women need to
know who you are do not try to be
somebody else to not try to be cool
enough for these 30 beautiful women to
date you
nobody is nobody ever will be well I've
talked to you about this before but you
know you were my first season of
bachelor franchise interviews with et I
was that your very first photo shoot
hi I'm Steve
see and I'm a bird walker tell me how
you walk Birds well I want them because
they think obesity is such a big problem
today and birds can fly but who's
walking them what if their legs get so
fat they can't even fly away so it's why
it's important to me oh I love to hear
more about it first of all it's good
babies children like we have showed up
with a glow up five years later Wow
absolute children so so young so naive I
would like to also take credit for the
fact that you still are interviewing
bachelors so if that bad of an
experience then I don't know what I was
thinking to think I've just started this
new job at Entertainment Tonight I have
this great idea let me interview this
guy in character I guess I was being
true to myself
it was reflective of what would be to
come but what were you thinking what I
was probably one of your I might have
been your first interview do you
remember what you're thinking when I
told you I'm gonna interview you as
stereotypes for the show well I think
you can see in my face it's very similar
to look at my faces every single person
guys a limo it's like ah I don't I don't
belong here but I'm gonna try my best to
to react I do remember in my mind
thinking I want to be like witty here
like I what witty thing and like that's
never a good mindset to get into is I
want to be witty and so I just kind of
froze not knowing and I had no clue that
was one of your first interviews I
thought I was being interviewed by
somebody that was a long-term vet and
here we are I was referring they sent
you the newbie but I luckily here we are
and I thought your response was great
how is the ride that's that that's dry
humor Ben that's great you crushed it
[Music]